oh my goodness 200 300 400 400 billions
of people travel through airports every
year
675 with all those people comes a whole
lot of stuff so $8 number is 11 some of
that stuff ends up at this auction we do
it every fall and cleans up all the
items that people have abandon in the
airport lost in the airport automobiles
why not go for the shoe especially the
Red Box shoes 12 on that car 12 this
year we have a Mini Cooper which is one
of the nicer cars that we've seen the
Cadillac Escalade of the hor Steelers
player that one brought in a lot of
money two two but we're at the end of
the road all of this you got a nice buy
there
sir starts
here from Lost at the airport we
received a box of human remains to found
in Alabama a 40 karat Colombian in World
sometimes it's a good adventure and
sometimes not and sold at auction sold
at 7,000 this is the story of luggage
gone
[Music]
lost welcome to Seattle Tacoma
International Airport we want your
journey to be a safe one for all members
of your family wonder what happens to
your luggage after you check it
in we did today we're going to be
sending this GoPro down the Journey of
the bag and we're going to put this
protective case on here cuz we have no
idea exactly what this camera will be
encountering there we
go go ahead hello hi Sacramento the
final today great you are all set to go
awesome thank you than you
after your bag gets put on the initial
conveyor belt it goes through a series
of
conveyors sometimes several miles long
that will take the bag through an
automated security
screening if the x-ray technology
detects a Potential Threat in a bag it
sends the x-ray images to a TSA officer
who tries to resolve the threat if it's
still questionable TSA manually inspects
the bag less than 5% of bags are
physically inspected
when the bags leave security the
sortation systems will move the bags
over which then will go down a slide
down to the respective pier where an
agent will load the bag onto a
cart but these are more than just
bags they hold the clues to who we are
as
Travelers what we have in common and
What Makes Us
unique once the bags arrive out at the
aircraft they are uploaded onto the
aircraft and they're off to their
[Music]
destination or
not thanks for calling Seattle Airport
lost and found my name is Michelle how
can I help you oh my gosh oh
my oh interesting oh it's full of
stuff every day lost luggage Stacks up
an airports around the world I can't
judge a book by its cover and every item
has a different story hi how can I help
you I yeah I left something at T
yesterday what we do here is lots of
detective work Lots behind the scenes
there are people working around the
clock to reunite all the lost things
with their owners I'm looking for
Clues oh look at that this is what I
love about uh lost and found because you
can be your own
detective yeah they came from Hawaii I'm
always surprised by the type of items
that people leave
[Music]
behind got document
9816 we received a Costco envelope from
[Music]
TSA it looks like maybe like personal
postcards inside the envelope is
seasonal greeting cards that's a
Christmas card in a New Year the Seattle
International airport processes about
100 lost items every
day and this is from December 28th
1976 and during the holidays that
doubles this is
12459 these envelopes are seasonal
grading cards um seem to be very um
sentimental 200 every different item has
a different sense of emotion to it maybe
we could call Costco and give them that
order number and they'll be able to pull
it
up with about 430 commercial airports in
the US we're talking millions of lost
items each
year and that's not even including the
airlines play with Alaska Airlines a
proud member of the One World l in 2021
which was a year without that much
travel we handled 43,000 left on board
[Music]
items I would say I would have at least
once a day somebody coming towards me
and say I think I left it on board
one time I was working a flight and
another passenger comes over and says
hey I was on this plane it landed I
think I I left something of value in
there I said okay well what is it and he
says it's my
dentures so I went on board and it was
there on the floor and it was just the
dentur just right there so I grabbed a
couple of napkins to pick it up and he
also seemed very relieved to find them
they'll guesty planes and typically the
items are found by our
cleaners they will log the seat that
they found it in hopefully they'll have
the flight number that had just come in
they'll give that item either to the
customer service agent that met the
flight or if it's a late at night flight
they would bring it down to the baggage
service office if nobody claims those
items then they get sent here to Central
baggage services and then we try to make
a match the way I describe it is where
the lost and found for the whole Airline
anytime something's left on the plane
whether it's a pencil a wallet an iPad
everything gets sent here within 24
hours so we have a CPAP
machine at this stage we're kind of just
processing it sorting it from high value
low value then the next agent will
actually be able to do a little bit more
research we will start with high value
items um we do prioritize these items
I'll go ahead and start with this laptop
and loging in as found report the first
step that's taken is there any obvious
signs that we can reunite this item in
here we found a boarding pass we logg
that into a technology system that will
help us identify key words in a report
that the guest has hopefully made I do
have a loss report for the same flight
oh I have two so I will open each of
these up and see if I can get a matching
name which I did at that point we would
reach out to the guest I was calling to
let you know that I was able to match
your loss Report with an item that we
found in our warehouse awesome all
righty well thank you ma'am you are so
excited everyone was like I don't know
with no tag on it it's a 5050 chance and
I was like I just got that thing oh
right I did find your boarding pass so
that helped a lot thank you so much
ma'am okay thank you so much for
choosing Alaska you have a great
day I lost my bag we are always busy
here in in the lost and found office but
we get even busier during the
holidays this past holiday season we had
a suitcase of meat come into our office
the suitcase was filled from bottom to
top with nothing but deer meat goat meat
sausage many different items one
interesting item that we saw was uh a
guy who lost a box of rocks the guy came
through and he asked have you guys seen
any rubies no we haven't seen any rubies
he said well you probably wouldn't know
if they were rubies because they're raw
they look like rocks it was a box about
like this and when we brought him out he
goes yeah that's it that's
it we've all been there before I think
it's a a common thing we can all relate
to everybody's done it before I've done
it myself oh yeah um head headrest I've
lost several headrest too embarrass to
see how many a very nice lady said ma'am
is this yours I was so embarrassed said
yes it's mine thank you it was a gift
and then I had to run back and say it's
me I left my bag on board and they said
don't you work for an airline I said yes
to this day I still miss that ground
sweater Mark Jackson please return the
checkpoint for a left behind item lost
and found handles anything left behind
in security checkpoints in any general
airport
areas
all right let's go heading to checkpoint
GRE to start the day we're lost in
problem 70% of Seattle's lost items
comes from the TSA checkpoint all right
gentlemen excuse us
please first thing in the morning we
check our lost and found database and we
compile list from all five screening
checkpoints we got
9324 we go out to each individual
checkpoint and collect all their lost
and
found and last item
9015 excuse me gentlemen pre pandemic we
collected roughly 30,000 items on a
yearly basis so that one I need High
Travel seasons do produce a lot more
loss and found your summertime your
Spring Breaks especially holiday season
through three gotta no TSA meant a lot
less lost
items before TSA was established in 2001
passengers merely had to walk through a
metal
detector no removing belts or
shoes and as for back checks what back
checks with fewer items removed fewer
items were left
behind all right how you doing we're
going to meet you out at the back door
when the office opens up here at 8:00 in
the morning all right we come downstairs
with the bin or bins and we start
turning them over to the Port of Seattle
good morning hi good morning Michelle
how are you guys I'm good how you doing
you got got a lot of stuff for me today
that's right it's 3day work right come
on in the most common items that I've
seen left behind in the security
checkpoints are usually laptops gaming
consoles iPads 7478 I guess we're moving
to the laptop MH okay one of the most
unusual items that I've picked up
through the lost and found was actually
today it was a tortilla press
7582 cuz you never know when you want a
quadal right
yeah we have to check each one of the
item especially with the
clothing and
6847 okay so let's check the pockets
sorry there's something
there in a typical travel year nearly $1
million is Left Behind at TSA
checkpoints in cash JFK Airport takes
the cake with over
$98,000 with the bags as well we have to
go through it oh a lot of
books a if we get like a perishable
items inside those bags we have to take
them out it can only stay there for 24
hours you can imagine a bag with a
banana that sits there for a month it's
not going to be pretty a you know
sometimes you can't help but to feel
sorry for the mama who's traveling with
this
[Music]
baby going through all these items is a
process
okay all right we see you later see you
later guys and sometimes that process
bears oh my gosh unusual fruit there's
actually fish
[Music]
inside all right so this bag actually
came from TSA but there's no name on it
so let's see if we can find the name
okay lots of goodies
treats oh my
gosh there's actually fish
inside like real fish why
would this is why we have to
check
it's smelly smelly
fish and I don't know why they put that
in
so sorry we'll have to dump this right
away these items need to go out from the
bag and we have to dispose it
unfortunately because it's really
perishable items I'm interested to find
out what's inside this
[Music]
bag looks like rice that is um from the
bottom of the pot I don't know this
might be like
spices oh what's in I think this is
garlic
CH okay sorry they will all go
here aha
medication there is a medication here
which gives me a clue who it belongs to
yep there's a name so we can search for
the owner I'm assuming they were
supposed to to do sushi with that fish
but sorry have to go in
there and that's about it for this
bag when we receive lost and found bags
everything has to be registered from
inside
out hopefully the name on this
medication will lead us to the owner of
the
[Applause]
bag raw fish is just one of the many
strange lost items the Dublin
International Airport has seen a left
behind toilet life-sized mannequin and
headstone Pittsburgh International
Airport has its own laundry list of
unusual items when items are left
throughout the common areas of the
terminal they are then turned into to us
at the information
desk we store those items for 30 days
and try to make every attempt to reach
the owner some of the the strange items
that we have seen over the years a pair
of souvenir alligator heads a rice maker
a carpet steamer diving equipment false
teeth a 2500 page Vietnamese to English
dictionary that was very thick about
this thick all those bracelet if they
are then unclaimed we send them offsite
in preparation for the
[Music]
auction hey Tony oh hey detective Le
before the Seattle Airport even thinks
about an auction they let an actual
detective take a stab at finding owners
you got any good stuff for me this month
Yes actually I do uh our policy is to
hold on to items for 30 days three
tablets here okay um what we would call
high value items say a laptop or tablet
or cell phone um jewelry we will turn
those over to the
police many years ago with lost and
found because I have some experience
with computer forensics I felt that my
skills would help get some property back
to folks see next month see you next
month I just try to do an additional
check to try to get them get the
property back to the
[Music]
owners one of the easiest things is
checking them for stolen
status the lost and found just doesn't
have the ability to to do that so we
checked to see if these items have been
reported stolen
and see if there's a Sim in there it
looks like it might be a foreign Sim
over the years because of people's
concerns over security and and
everything it makes it a lot harder
sometimes to actually get property back
to folks and unfortunately I'm not able
to read it it's one of those Sims that I
just I'm not able to read so with this
particular phone I'm pretty much at a at
a dead end serial number is not reported
stolen um I'm not able to get any phone
number off the um off the sim card all
right
so it is kind of frustrating that you
know we'll have a a $2,000 laptop
sitting there here and it's not reported
stolen we don't have a name and we start
running out of options so this is one
that came in last month that I still
haven't uh had a chance to get to yet
and we've got a lot of different pieces
here here and between these we should be
able to
hopefully get a name that we can get a
phone number
[Music]
on sometimes losing your luggage is out
of your
control it looks like a lot of uh gmen
must have guys have a weight and balance
issue so they didn't send a lot of that
when you're out at the airport and your
bag doesn't come off the bagage claim we
know that that feeling is really hard
I'm going to call the gate to see if
they when a bag is not able to be
identified to a guest the airports will
continue to try and find the guest for
the first 5 days on the sixth day the
bag is then tagged to be sent here to
Central
baggage where we will begin a more
intensive search there's a a a tag with
a name there is some sense of ownership
on our part that we didn't necessarily
care for that item like we should have
I'm sorry that your baggage didn't get
to go with you we have it here and we
certainly want to get it back to you
it's in our nature to want to rectify
that situation this is a left on board
item as of right now we have yet to find
that owner a photo album that was given
from we believe a wife to a husband we
nicknamed The Gentleman on the front the
pointing guy because throughout the
whole entire book all he is doing is
pointing Every Witch Way at every item a
left behind item is a little bit
different than a checked item because we
don't necessarily know who that item
belonged to so we created a found report
hoping that the guest had submitted a
lost report as of right now there was no
trace results which means that nothing
in our system matched the two of them we
actually pulled out every single photo
hoping that there was something written
on the back of one of them no luck there
in one of the photos towards the
back there is a boat which is registered
within the state of
Washington and so I ended up up calling
the state of Washington to see if I
could get any vessel information but
doesn't this look like him what's next
for us is we're hoping to actually use
the power of social media in our favor
that looks like Lake Chalan and so we
just hope that everyone can help us try
and figure out who the pointing guy
is checked baggage on the other hand has
a better chance of making it home the
amount of times that we're unable to
reunite a check bag with a guest is very
small we're talking a fraction of a
percent across all Airlines the chance
of never getting your bag back is less
than half a
percent but with billions of people
traveling every year that half a percent
adds up we're talking over a million
bags
worldwide many of them end up
[Music]
here my name is uh DNE gri
my job here at unclean baggage as
Transportation specialist I go all over
the country Coast to Coast picking up
lost luggage from
Airlines I'm picking up luggage on a
weekly basis a lot of miles a lot of
hours uh I listen to a lot of podcast U
I listen to a lot of top radio probably
too much
sometimes sometimes just
music sometimes I'm Amazed by the number
of bags that we
get
every day I open
dozens it depends on the size it depends
on what's in the bag I usually open
dozen Poncho kitchen wear M lots of
cologne lots of
[Music]
shoes we're at inclan baggage and we're
a retail store in Scottsboro Alabama and
we work and partner directly with the
major airlines and we sell unclaimed
baggage
it's a nice shirt have some nice clean
socks clean these shoes look pretty good
that all I got started with my
dad who was a ham radio operator back in
the
1960s one day a gentleman got on the
radio and said I heard this big problem
with unclaimed bags we have so many of
them we don't know what to do with them
my dad uh he said I think I see an
opportunity there I may be able to help
you my dad borrowed $300 from one of my
grandfathers he borrowed my other
grandfather's 1965 Chevy C10 pickup
truck and he headed up towards
Washington DC and bought his first load
of unan bags from Trailway bus
lines and and then we segwayed into the
airline world air travel in the 70s
looked a little different than it does
today the new 747 jet boasted spiral
staircases and smoking was permitted the
alcohol was flowing and meals were
carved to
order sitting in coats was like going to
the movies in the early' 70s it would
have started with Eastern Airlines and
they lost a ton of bags that was our
first Airline and now we work with
pretty much all of them throughout the
industry in 50 years of going through
other people's stuff they've come across
some surprising
items one of the most noteworthy to me
is the 40 karat Colombian
emerald it was in the toe of a sock
rolled up in the corner of a
suitcase I don't think I'll ever forget
[Music]
it today Dwayne is the guy delivering
all this unclaimed baggage to Scottsboro
and that's where this process begins
Miss debah here's your next bag thank
you as they're opening the bag going
through their archaeological dig they're
deciding if we're going to sell it if we
need to recycle it or if we need to
donate it and this is a nice surprise
ceramic heater we open bags soort
everything out send them to the
Departments that where they
belong that's nice The Beetles yeah a
third of everything we get is recycled
nice pants check the
pockets more underwear everything looks
pretty fresh that's nice so obviously
people travel with undergarments we
never sell any used undergarments we're
going to recycle those with fabric waste
you will be amazed at how many people
travel with brand new and packaged
underwear we'll price those and put them
on our cell FL to sell it does feel like
I'm stepping into somebody else's life
like this might be a ukulele
and I
like seeing where people have
been make sure make sure it's in tune or
Out Of
Tune the bags usually tell a story and
you never know what you're going to find
and it's kind of an adventure kind of at
times sometimes it's a good adventure
and sometimes not so one of the most
hair raising things we found at
unclaimed baggage was a live rattlesnake
one of our openers as she was opening a
duffel
bag a live rattlesnake came slithering
out of it I think that they released it
out behind the building yeah to let him
live on live another
day in Pittsburgh some of the most
surprising unclaimed items are cars the
abandoned vehicles are always the most
popular items we're usually left with
between 10 and 20 cars a year
we contact the owners the police contact
the owners Department of Transportation
contacts the owners and if there's still
no response from those folks then it
comes to us for the auction $2500 on
Nissan 1,000 bid 122 1,000 get 122 get
12 $1,100 on the KNE side now 12 I think
some of the cars can be left behind if
people are on maybe extended vacations
1,000 2,000 3 4 4 4 5 5 6
if the car doesn't have a lot of value
they may not want to pay some of the
parking fees or the towing storage fees
that the airport would charge and they
just simply abandon the
car1 sold it 7,000 there are some left
behind items that hold more of a
sentimental value so got this bag a
couple of weeks
ago I'm going to do a secondary research
on
it got this Brown case here let's see
what's in this
case oh
[Music]
interesting got this Brown case here
what we're looking at now is a Ace
Hardware bag with a brown box
photos Metals military Metals Inside the
Box what we have are military Metals a
name tag and a lot of pictures we got a
naval Reserve organization Association
card and a selective Services card since
those are all in one person's name I'm
going to try and look him up so I've got
one person in Kansas they're
51 so that would not be them because of
the selector Services card it's going
back to to
55 and then I have another person but
they're
deceased we also have a photograph of a
baby which has a date of
1987 and it also has her name on there
let's try the young lady that was
actually on this picture we have her
listed here as
well I've been able to find several
people that appear to be associated with
this person I've placed several phone
calls yes hi Maryann my name is Tony so
hopefully one of these people know who
this is and we'll call
back looks like shirts back in Alabama a
third of all the luggage unclaimed
baggage receives is sold and it looks
clean but we'll launder
it we're very proud of our laundry
facility uh we are actually the largest
in the state of Alabama we process more
in one month than most of them do in an
entire
year it's just surprising what people
Tak in their luggage dishes uh
silverware water bottles is it's there
is a lot of
those I guess the one that stands up
most I washed car mats why somebody took
that on their vacation I don't
know Electronics get the full workup
too most we get in is usually headphones
stuff like that so it's really just
getting all germs everything cleaned off
after we clean them we test them to make
sure they're functioning and from there
they're going to data wipe
everything our pricers will then price
the merchandise whether it's apparel
shoes Jewelry accessories
Electronics the jewelry counter is where
you'll find some big ticket items this
this diamond engagement ring appraised
for a little over $10,000 and we have it
listed for a little over
$5,000 this is a emerald inam tennis
bracelet we have it listed at a little
over
$14,000 but there are some things you
can't put a price tag on in the 9s a
shipping container showed up with a
guidance system for fighter jets and
it's a the department of the US Navy
handle with Extreme Caution I am worth
my weight in
gold the actual gold is authenticated
appraised priced and put on the
floor these look like they are diamonds
but then I can also use my diamond
tester and it does test
Diamond this ruby ring is currently the
most expensive item in the
[Music]
store the most expensive item we've ever
sold in our store was a men's Platinum
prolex it's just a pretty cool
experience to come be a part of and see
what all people
lose okay Lot number one we have a whole
lot of ear ranks some of the lost
jewelry in Pittsburgh has people
scratching their heads we are always
surprised with how many wedding rings
are turned in to the lost and found
mainly men's wedding rings we're not
sure why a lot of them are claimed but
there are still a good amount that are
turned over to us at the auction we also
this year have a pair of stiletto heels
that are brand new um so I think that
will maybe draw in the
ladies I think that people are
interested in just seeing what items are
left
behind hi uh I lost the case of
harmonicas is there any chance that you
guys have it okay let me go see if I can
find it I grabbed it off the plane and
then I was coming here and I went
outside to wait for my ride and I just
like set it against the
wall I thought for sure that it was
gone
yeah thankfully some kind soul decided
to uh turn it in they were pretty
intrigued by what was
inside thank you so much
[Music]
apprciate yeah so
work if you lose an item at one of
paris's airports it will eventually end
up at the world's very first lost and
found office established by Napoleon in
1804 the Bureau of found objects has
received a human skull a Taxidermy
Lobster and a saber from
1892 this is one that came in last month
that I still but in Seattle some of the
Lost items end up with this guy
um the logo on here doesn't appear to go
with any sort of
school I'm looking for something that
may talk about like a particular school
then I can know a particular City where
that person lives when we go to get a
name a lot of times it helps if we have
middle initials information like that um
or a city will help as well what we
have
kidss Kindle Fire on that Kindle Fire
tablet the parent had set up two
profiles for the kids he just used
initials for the children we got a name
and a midle
initial did you lose something file a
lost item we might get lucky with this
name I have uh different databases that
I can use and if it's a unique enough
name I can try to track down the owner
that way we only got one let's give it a
call sometimes the time zone can help me
kind of pinpoint the region and increase
the chances that I'm actually getting
the correct person hi this is detective
donin with the pter Seattle Police
Department sometimes there's enough
breadcrumbs of items in a in a
particular bag that allows me to kind of
track them down yep yep Curious George
is here he's sitting on my desk yeah so
we got the uh the Kindle the um backpack
the colorful backpack the uh um Curious
George and we'll get him
home Curious George is lucky he'll make
it home but at unclaimed baggage
millions of items end up in other
people's homes some of those items
aren't what you'd expect it's amazing
what people travel with about 20 years
ago they had this automatic in and I I
mean oh uh I said is that for sale and
they said yes and I said I want it this
is uh a charm bracelet that I have been
uh collecting charm for several years
one of the most interesting things that
we've gotten consistently over the years
have been wedding gowns I can remember
at least two full suits of armor we've
had a number of kilts a number of bag
pipes we we actually had a a camera show
up that was was a camera for the space
shuttle had been on space shuttle
missions and and we got that back into
the hands of
NASA for the Seattle Airport lost and
found getting items back into the right
hands is the goal okay so we'll get the
label that's the possible owner because
it matches the medication we'll give
them a call Mrs K oh it's your mom oh
gotcha you know we found um vegetables
and fish in there I did find a a match
for the bag with the raw fish it looks
like they did file a loss report and
unfortunately yeah can't stay in the bag
so we have to throw them away okay the
bag is confirmed with the owner and they
will pick it up tomorrow all right we'll
see you tomorrow Mr
Kim at the end of the day there are
ultimately items that go
unclaimed many of them are donated to
various
organizations but some go to the dogs
our bomb can9 unit uses some of the
suitcases and clothing items and even
some of the the cosmetics and toiletry
items in these unclaimed bags because
they're able to then incorporate that
into their training for their bomb
dogs good morning again l ladies and
gentlemen we'd like to welcome you all
to the auction we're glad if the
electronics are still in good shape we
can send them off to auction and lost
and found from the airport accumulation
for the oneyear period we're here at
Pittsburgh International Airport's
annual auction we're getting ready to
auction off all of the loss and found
and items that were abandoned throughout
the last year here at the airport come
on now let's have a sale sale
time it's always interesting to see what
items get left here I'm looking for uh
Hardware either myself or for resale
when I saw these lots of laptops I'm
hoping to donate them to my Civil Air
Patrol unit Electronics they their ear
pods I would be on that truck but she'll
kill me if I drive it home so I I can't
do
that that Mini Cooper seems like a nice
car I'm going to bid on it and see what
happens the auction company will accept
the money order Cashers check certified
check this year there's a Mini Cooper
and pickup truck so personally I'm
interested to see you know what are the
cars going for those are always the big
ticket items here one of the cars we did
have was a former Pittsburgh Steelers
player he had since moved on to Chicago
his car was parked here in the lot and
he just never responded and didn't come
back and get his car so It ultimately
went to auction it was a Cadillac
Escalade at London's heow airport the
unclaimed baggage gets auctioned off
twice a month the difference here is
there's no peeking in the bags before
you bid going once anybody bit 15,000
going twice anybody bit 15,000 000 sold
it
$4,750 out of all the Left Behind items
the Mini Cooper brought in the most cash
but every single item was sold this is
like totally crazy like I had not
expected like any kind of this kind of
stuff but being a big fan of the NFL and
the Steelers I got a couple of our game
waren
jerseys nice and dirty meaning their
game
one I won six lots of jewelry how much
did I spend uh 2600 275 for pones that's
not bad $8,000 which was actually our
our limit why not go for the shoes
especially the red bottom shoes I think
it's still setting in that I actually
won them most years at the airport
Authority auction raises more than
$150,000 the money that's raised goes to
the airport Authority Foundation which
supports military scholarships those
types of things yeah this is our first
time probably won't be the last though
oh yeah come back next year for sure go
home and play with our new toys
an auction is one way to get rid of
uncleaned baggage but at the unclaim
baggage center there's so much lost
stuff it's impossible to sell it
[Music]
all at unclaimed baggage you might think
you'd find a lot of well baggage but
that's not the
case many years ago we started donating
luggage to the Department of Human
Resources
and that actually came from a newspaper
article that had talked about foster
children and they were giving them
garbage bags and so I remember just
being taken by that
[Music]
article unclaimed baggage decided to
take matters into their own
hands we stopped all luggage going to
the floor anything that we sold and we
started holding these for about 2 weeks
and I can remember calling them and
saying we're on our way with their first
load and we filled the
sidewalks we decided no children in our
community was going to go with a black
bag ever again and then we started the
decorating we thought you know hey look
this is a gift so that's where we
decided to start painting
it the last third of the luggage that
ends up at uncleaned baggage gets
donated we get so much excess there
could be no way that we could sell it
all and so we have found Partners to get
this product into the hands of people
that can use it the uh Cosmetics that
are in the bag we can put those in the
back in I have a small charity
organization and uh I come to pick up
some donations from unclaim
baggage couple years ago a buddy and
mine and both uh Navy Vietnam veterans
were traveling down the road and we saw
a veteran he was homeless and he didn't
have a coat and it was pretty cold
outside so my buddy and I went purchased
the cat for him and then we decided that
well wait a while maybe there's more
people out there so him and I went
around looking for veterans or basically
anybody that needed a coat D my dentist
up here informed me that hey unclaimed
baggage has a department that they
donate stuff why don't you talk to them
then the whole thing just exploded cuz
now we had access to hundreds of coats
our charity became a distributorship if
you will we found people who needed
stuff we had a a sponsor that would give
that to us and we just gave it out and
that's that's how it is right now that's
what we've been
doing I cannot begin to give you a
number of tens of thousands of pairs of
iear probably each year comes through
our
store one year we got
55,000 pairs of glass glasses and
sunglasses from
McLean these are topnotch glasses and
readers I mean the readers these these
folks on airplanes don't buy cheap
readers with all the giving that we do
we do still have luggage available in
store what would unclean baggage be
without a few bags on the
[Music]
Shelf does it have a lot of little um
knicknacks in that brown box yes ma yeah
my dad and has all these tiny little pin
you get my voicemail no this is my
daughter phone number ah okay I don't
know how that even transpired there was
a baby picture of her we saw the name
and then we were able to look it up by
the name we went through Linkedin and
and true people search and wow
everything the woman who called back was
actually the daughter of the gentleman
that the Box belonged to
and he is deceased it wasn't me that it
was my son so thank you so much for that
is a real memory thing it was his
grandfather right really wanted she
asked that we keep the item for her for
a few days until she gets here and we'll
see you in yes ma'am I'll be here bright
ey so what did happen to all the Lost
items we've been tracking
[Music]
what's the best thing about my
job seeing the joy in people's face when
their item is
returned
[Music]